bonsoir les petits amis j'ai une
surprise
j'ai une surprise oui et bien descend
vite chez nicolas et pimprenelle car tu
me paraît bien un patient juge veut pas
trop ma casquette mes petites affaires
et hop
michelle orpe hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop rojo à
eau et un bâton
j'attends du canal
c'est un musicien quel jeu les musiques
[Musique]
non
et
[Musique]
bravo monsieur musicienne aupravant
vous êtes nounou ou vous êtes à monsieur
musiciens je vous laisse deviner
je ne vous dire tant de
connard tu sais comment on va faire pour
savoir si ces nounours non 10 mois est
haute
bonne idée
monsieur les musiciens vous voulez je me
rabats de l'aja les musiques de
l'harmonica ça vous plains oui on vous
écoute monsieur le musicien
[Musique]
m
mais ce duel d'abord
[Musique]
messi mouvement contre reconnaître
il est pour moi il est temps pour toi
gros joueur d'harmonica merci mes amis
je vous promets que je vous jours est
souvent encore dollars monitor vannes à
tétines noces tu viens nicolas on va se
coucher ne mangent pas tous tu te
rendrais mahb bonne nuit
on
[Musique]
oui
ah voilà notre nounours
alors tu es content ou ou la musique
leur musique ce bon ballon en route
mangeurs de miel bonne nuit les enfants
photo bourg
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
oh